president Trump finished out his first
year at the White House today putting
pen to paper to seal his first big
legislative victory tax cuts for
Americans listen the bottom line is this
is the biggest tax cuts and reform in
the history of our country this is
bigger than actually President Reagan's
many years ago a very honored by it
it's a gonna be a tremendous thing for
the American people this is a little
picture of it it fits nicely in the box
I said take it out of the box because
people have to see and all of this
everything in here is really tremendous
things for businesses for people for the
middle class for workers corporations
are literally going wild over this I
think even beyond my expectations he
called that Democrats again for opposing
the bill but he did project optimism
that both sides will work together again
in the new year
I think the Democrats will really regret
the Democrats already regret it
you know they have their typical thing
it's for the rich they know that's not
true
and they've been called out on it by the
media actually but the Democrats very
much regret it they wanted to be a part
of it just doesn't work out but I really
do believe and I said on social media
today I really do believe we're going to
have a lot of bipartisan work done the
president is now in Florida where he
will spend Christmas break kimberley
I'll go to you first
they certainly ended the year on a high
note yeah absolutely and you can tell he
feels very happy about it was almost
quite and sweet about the press he's
like he's nice man he gave him the pens
and everything exactly a little gifts
parting gifts for an awesome yeah he
loves the crew guys yeah and I thought
it was very positive because he really
wanted to get this done I think he feels
like okay we've got like you know four
tires on the car now like we know how to
drive it we're pointing in the right
direction we know how to work
cooperatively together in terms of you
know a variety of different constituents
within the Republican Party and I think
he feels like he's kind of coasting now
headed in the right direction and he
might be able to get some of the other
things done that he wanted I mean
besides you know tax reform he's
obviously very bold on every great
chin he's got good economy numbers and
then of course you know Isis he's doing
fantastic as it relates to national
money has Jesse a better relationship
now with the leaders on the hill mm-hmm
McConnell and Ryan he couldn't have he
didn't have he couldn't haven't spent
enough time talking about how good they
are yeah no one saw that coming
a couple months back they asked Mitch
McConnell if he likes the president's
tweeting and he goes this week I just
started to like it said a very lot of
nice things about I mean I get tax cuts
you got judges you have Isis and the
economy is roaring and you know it's
been a great year and now all these
companies are giving thousand dollar
bonus checks to their employees a bunch
of you have Wells Fargo raising the
minimum wage to $15 an hour and Boeing
is going to invest 300 million dollars
in their employees so that's good but
there's obviously a huge risk going into
the midterms and then a phrase speaker
Pelosi should send chills up the
president's spine the house I think is a
real risk and they have to spend a lot
of money but you know what Republicans
have a lot of money they raise ten
million dollars in October forty two
million dollar cash on hand
the DNC only has five million dollar
cash on hands so they're in a lot of
trouble if they think it's gonna be a
wave with that money to be a trickle but
President Trump want proved you don't
need to spend the most money in order to
win but do you think that do you agree
with him that the Democrats are already
regretting their vote on tax reform no
that's more you know Trump talk and
Trump boastfulness and the Trump bubble
I mean he just has no idea what's going
on there's incredible because even today
you know when he had people coming in
and he's talking to people who were
formerly aides like Corey Lewandowski
and Reince Priebus and they're telling
him quite plainly that 2018 looks like
it's going to be not just a way but a
tidal wave and he has to watch out so
he's talking about rejiggering people
inside the White House to better prepare
himself and the question is who will he
bring in and what changes will be made
because you got a number of people
including Dina power for example leaving
the White House people walking out so
question is who stays and what did they
do to try to gird themselves but I think
with regard to the tax plane I mean all
he has to do is look at the polls well I
think that though I think that he has an
advantage
and that it's not the rnc necessarily
that needs to spend the money but you
have other entities willing to help to
go out and sell tax reform because their
job isn't done they have to go out and
remind people over and over again but
this is a good thing and they hope and
they're hoping that the economics will
bear out and that those poll numbers
start to change yes and I think the the
average American when they start to see
the tax cut I think it's gonna resonate
with them and I don't think this tax cut
for the rich is gonna work I think that
this Donald Trump behind the desk just
winging it with the reporters this is
the the approach if I was his
communications director I would say
you've got to do everything this way
there are there's there's rally you
don't like it in front of the helicopter
where you can't hear him
no he tries different things so you got
the rally Trump the base loves rally
Trump the establishment loves
teleprompter Trump they want him to be
things out on the on the you know they
want him to bend it scripted this
unscripted you're right on that I think
this is the way to gone I think you're
you do call me I'm trying to be like
somebody on the five you know who my
father called Oh interesting my
father-in-law called me today did you
watch President Trump my father a degree
that great American so he Belvedere
watch him truck driver
teamster he watched Trump today and he
was very impressed with him and I think
the average American they'd like to see
this laid-back looks like he recharged
when you're able to just riff a little
bit like that
yes Kimberly so you're just he's able to
he did take a few questions from the
press yeah well he's just very
comfortable in his own skin he loves it
he thinks it's magnificent variety he
really enjoys being Donald Trump he
enjoys being president Trump the deal
maker he likes to be able to give people
compliments and love them you know
that's why he was happy today they'd
give him McConnell some compliments
sprinkle some sugar the love sandwich
I'm Paul Ryan that's fine he's happy
when he's the giving tree' okay it's so
comfortable he would add a press
conference because he's so worried in
fact that there's so much going on that
people would actually ask him tough
questions and maybe get him off of that
relaxed thing that time Shalu I don't
think the president's afraid bond that's
the president I think when he was
running for president did every single
interview that he ever possibly could so
he's not afraid and he relishes
sometimes going out there and
manhandling the press I think the
concern was instead of asking legitimate
questions about policy they were gonna
ask them ridiculous questions that was
going to get him off topic about Russia
and I don't think they wanted to send in
the moral hago in a bad mood right but I
don't think that was the issue I think
the issue was if you start saying to
people hey how come so much of this goes
to the rich and you had promised as a
populist candidate that you were going
to work out something for is direct
missus average American I have to sell
the plan I wasn't gonna have to and he
went like this which was funny but he
will have to sell the plan I think that
was a ferocious job to go out to build
those oceans not oh now we don't have
aught Moroso we're gonna have to have
someone in there well I don't know like
you said sell the plan if it's like
that's part of what they were
complaining about to him today he
doesn't have a successful public liaison
office but he I mean this is a difficult
thing to sell because it's so
contradictory that even when you do
party politics is sport you know oh the
Republicans over here Democrats over
here what you see is Republicans are
saying and independence especially this
tax plants to everybody I would get out
there and I'd say look at your paycheck
or if it's direct deposit go online and
look at it you're welcome and there's
more where that came look at growing
income inequality look at pass-throughs
that allow the rich to structure their
income so that they don't have to pay
the same tax rate as working people this
is one you want to pay more taxes check
that box no what do you mean that on
your return you're talking about nobody
wants to pay more not paying enough the
idea is the idea is that he had promised
that working-class middle-class people
were going to get the lion's share of us
instead now he says the real benefit of
this plan was reducing tax rates on
corporations Jesse and what did the
corporation's do they showered their
workers $1,000 but where is this I'm
waiting to see a look at AT&T look what
you see a few companies and you see
that's the Rosen or Comcast get $1,000
bonus check that's pretty good yeah well
he's back to get out of here I'm all for
it by the way my son's there so I hope
that's right here so yeah bye your debt
of president ha ha ha
Kimberly they did have this meeting with
the president about 2018 and apparently
like if it's high stakes because you
want to be able to try to defy the odds
to entry shows that usually a president
loses seats in the in the first midterm
that is a normal thing they just don't
have that many seats and one of the guys
I was talking to today said that the 12
Republicans who voted against tax reform
because their constituents are so mad
that their taxes are going up that those
seats are quite vulnerable and if you
win those twelve you are halfway to
taking back the majority you're
absolutely right I mean it's risky
business you know and that's why it was
so important and pivotal but maybe those
constituents should they should have
thought about that in terms of
supporting you know the tax bill which
really is quite you know but they even
support it because their constituents
said they liked it well but nevertheless
now let's see if they're able to then
get you know reelected
I don't know we'll see what happens but
problem is there isn't enough padding
there isn't enough kind of room there to
be able to give up few seats here and
there because it's already too close of
a margin however let's see how this does
in the beginning of the year what else
he's able to accomplish that can help
Boyett into the midterm elections to
give him some positive momentum and the
other thing is don't forget you know the
campaigner the campaigner in chief in
that Donald Trump is very good at
getting out there and really boosting
enthusiasm and turnout and I'm sure he's
gonna do that because he may lay awake
today said you know hey the Democrats
will work with me when it comes to
infrastructure and I immediately thought
but mr. president where's the money
because what you've done here is you've
created this huge deficit right and
there's no added revenue so Democrats
will then say but mr. present unless you
want to change your tax plan to provide
the money however on raising taxes again
floating a gas tax well look also losing
a couple of seats doesn't necessarily
isn't bad for a presidency it worked
wonders for Bill Clinton's career
because he lost a lot of seats remember
the contract with I mean but they could
have been they could run on welfare
reform and other things I mean they were
they benefited from Republican ideas
yeah but don't you agree that sometimes
losing seats that changes the presidency
but it's not necessarily bad for a
president's re-election prospects well
if they bring in crunch Chuck and Nancy
then maybe he could make a deal and
triangulate like he did
in August in September I looked at the
map the Democrats in the Senate they are
defending 26 seats 24 24 26 and the
Republicans are only defending like four
or five so and it looks like the most
vulnerable Republicans Jeff Flake the
next most vulnerable yet they're all
Democrats yeah and so I think if the
president goes to a Montana or a South
Dakota or I excuse me North Dakota and
does some rallies and throws a lot of
catechins don't even have a candidate
yet that's the other thing I know what a
nominate a candidate like Roy Moore
that's gonna flame out apparently is
trying to primary John Barrasso the
senator from Wyoming that would not be
as odious so there now that's your you
guys have to deal with that but you've
still had the civil war raging inside
the party and Bannon is still a player I
actually think that that's why I
disagree and that's why I don't think
that the I don't think that
establishment Republicans want him just
to be scripted I think what they wanted
was for him to work cooperatively with
them in order to help get his agenda
passed which was what happened on tax
reform and Paul Ryan said we learned the
lesson on health care reform and the
things that we did that didn't go well
what happened this time is when they had
the President as the head coach and he's
getting brings everyone in the locker
room he's like okay you guys you guys go
out on the field you work out the
details and we're gonna come back here
and huddle and then we're gonna sign
this bill we're gonna like take across
the goal-line go about that I know I was
so I was like being on a high wire
without a net even is doing a sports
metaphor there but I think I I think you
spiked it